[російською] Підключено успішно.
[російською] Ну, що один, один, один...
Чик-чик-чик-чик-чик,
ту-ду-ту-ду-тук-тук-тук, Зіна-Зіна-Зіна..
О, може, я одразу перевірю музику,
чи нормально вона звучить.
[сміється]
Світла немає!
Все зникло!
Не бачив ти нічого.
Банди.
Ага!
До речі, знаєте, як треба руки правильно мити?
Ти намилюєш руки і милиш їх до того,
як доспіваєш пісню
[англійською] «З Днем народження тебе».
Коли ти доспівав пісню [англійською] «З Днем народження тебе»,
значить, у тебе всі мікроби померли.
І можна сміливо братися за роботу на кухні.
Я багато років їм дуже смачний сніданок.
І колись подумав, що цим смачним рецептом
варто поділитися з людством.
Ми придумали з власниками цього бару.
Я їм запропонував додати цей сніданок у меню їхнього бару.
Вони відповіли: «Давайте, окей».
От якраз сьогодні той день,
коли я прийшов показати як готую цей сніданок.
І щоб всі, хто хоче,
зараз могли його скуштувати.
Орегано підходить, чорний перець — ні.
Вибирай, що тобі потрібно.
Куркуму я додаю.
[Банди наспівує]
Це магазин «Абецешка».
Це такі магазини, де можна придбати
продукти харчування, цигарки, каву.
І обираючи місце для якогось віддаленого ефіру,
я подумав, що треба таке місце,
де треба вийти із зони комфорту, де буде багато людей.
Ну от, власне, такий експеримент,
час від часу я роблю такі речі.
Мені здається, це цікаво.
Для того щоб якось наблизитись до місця,
звідки ми віщаємо, я б хотів поспілкуватися з кимось.
У нас є люди, які прийшли купувати каву,
є дівчата, які роблять каву.
Добрий день, хочете взяти участь в акції?
Даєте правильну відповідь, я Вам купую каву.
Я на роботу поспішаю.
Нумо швиденько, яку каву тут найчастіше
купують люди: еспресо, капучино чи лате?
Я — капучино.
[сміється]
Це неправильна відповідь.
Перед цим ми з'ясували,
що найчастіше продається еспресо.
Добрий день, хочете взяти участь в акції?
Ну, не всі хочуть потрапляти у ефір,
а з працівниками все ясно —
вони і так знають правильну відповідь.
Так, все готово.
Вау!
— Ти будеш?
— Так, звичайно.
Отже, за правилами воно ставиться не на хліб,
а просто хліб в прикуску, але можна і так.
Я просто люблю порушувати правила.
Як на мене — вдалося.
Зважаючи на те, що я вперше на цій кухні
готував це, то вийшло — кльово.
Це вулиця Жимайте, я тут живу вже 19 років.
І сталося так, що я ще коли
про цю вулицю нічого не знав,
в дитинстві друг мого батька
розповів таку історію про неї.
Одного разу один художник їхав у художфонд,
який тут близько.
Він сів у таксі, і таксист каже: «Куди Вас везти?»
А той відповідає: «На Жимайте».
Він [таксист] каже: «Я нажму куди треба,
кажіть куди везти вас». «Так на Жимайте» .
Ну і батьки сміялися, і я сміявся.
Потім ми їхали від друзів, сіли в таксі,
таксист спитав: «Куди вас везти?».
Я кажу: «На Жимайте».
Коли ми їхали, я згадав цю історію і друзям,
які їхали зі мною в таксі, її розказав.
Минув час, аналогічна ситуація,
ми від інших якихось друзів теж на таксі.
Я знову кажу таксисту що,
він питає куди, я кажу: «на  Жимайте».
А він каже: «О , знаєте таку історію: одного разу
один художник сів у таксі і хотів їхати на Жимайте.
І таксист  йому каже:
«Я нажму, а ви кажіть, куди їхати».
Тобто...
Мені дуже сподобалось, що таксисти між собою
спілкуються і розповідають одне одному.
[сміється]
— Привіт.
— Так, привіт.
[сміється]
Ну нехай...
В Ужгороді всі хороші люди знайомляться
рано чи пізно, це не неуникно.
Олексія я вперше побачив по телебаченню,
ну дуже давно, не знаю,
скільки років [тому], він був зовсім юний.
А з Олексою ми познайомились
через його дружину — Ліну.
Коли вона приїздила до батьків, ми завжди бачились...
Разом пікнікували і ходили в гості одне до одного
Це отут є велика частина
«Чорного періоду» стоїть, так званого.
Це був мій достатньо такий великий проєкт,
який складався з більше 80-ти робіт:
інсталяції та аудіоінсталяції.
І ідея цього була така:
я як художник дуже змінився.
Тому що раніше я робив дуже яскраві речі
з відкритим кольором і тому подібне.
А тут я себе обмежив у палітрі, аби показати
чорно-білий світ, у якому ми живемо.
У нас зараз війна йде.
У людей почалося дуже феноменальне явище
під час соціальних серйозних катаклізмів —
чорно-біле сприйняття дійсності.
Свій – чужий, це добре – це погано.
Я хотів показати, що в такому є дуже багато нюансів.
Треба це все дуже сильно відрізняти.
Що твій друг може опинитись ворогом,
що навпаки твій ворог може виявитись людиною,
яка і не ворог насправді.
Тобто треба сприймати це з холодною головою.
Це було художнє завдання,
що це окремі речі,
які як шматок якоїсь дійсності,
напівабстрактної,
які складаються так, що за цими фрагментами
можна створити якусь картину дійсності.
А не просто по одному фрагменту дивитись на світ.
У мене дружина з Ужгорода, побудувала
тут майстерню, тут можна було працювати.
І Київ...
Основна причина, він не задовільняв,
це було таке міжчасся повністю,
мені часто набридали вечірки, інші речі.
Я подумав, що якщо далі займатись мистецтвом,
якось вирішив, що тут можна непогано працювати.
Тут є художні училища, тут є художня академія.
Тут є закарпатська школа мистецтва,
яка відома в Україні, яку заснували люди,
які вчилися на Заході.
До окупації Закарпаття радянськими військами...
Вони всі вчились в Празі, Парижі,
Будапешті, тобто Мюнхені.
Вони мають абсолютно західноєвропейську традицію,
тому вона була унікальна в Радянському Союзі.
Є якісь речі, на яких можна базуватись.
Це корейська популярна музика.
Мобілка розряджається, і в принципі ми вже
годину десять хвилин перебуваємо в «Зіні».
Я взагалі, та і не тільки я, всі тут
в стоячому варіанті, бачте, ніхто тут не сидить.
«Зіна» — це той момент,
коли всі стоять на ногах, до того ж..
Ви цілу добу працюєте чи як ?
Дванадцять.
Дванадцять годин, потім важко,
мабуть, відійти від роботи, чи не так?
Звично, звикається.
Звично, ті хто пройшов цю школу,
ті нормально собі чухають.
Я дякую всім хто слухав ефір «Єден на Єден»!
[англійською] Любов, мир, єдність.
Так, я потихеньку буду відмикатись.
Що це таке взагалі?
Так хоч що робиться, незрозуміло тут.
Я вам розповім.
Дякую.
[сміється]
Це будинок побуту, тут найдешевша
оренда в місті, тут студія радіо «Єден».
Це моя дружина Мар'яна.
У нас радіо для однієї людини, ми робимо акції.
Це наприклад всі учасники акції «Плейлист однієї людини».
Я вирішив вішати тут фотографії тому,
що радіо для однієї людини.
От приходить хтось з цих людей в студію,
а тут в рамочці висить їхня фотографія,
їм однозначно буде приємно.
От ця стіна, я думаю, вона обросте
десь до якихось таких можливих просторів.
Будь-хто може надіслати його,
від 10 до 100 пісень.
Я працював на іншій станції.
Я останнім часом там не міг робити те,
що мені подобається,
у мене були конфліктні ситуації з керівництвом.
І я щось думав, взагалі будь-хто
з нас хоче свою справу мати.
Ну от так воно якось і запустилось.
Я написав на Фейсбук:
«Як ви думаєте чи можливо створити радіо в Ужгороді,
яке б жило за рахунок слухачів виключно?»
І люди, багато хто написав:
«Так, давай. Гроші, ми підтримаємо».
Я розписав, скільки мені потрібно для техніки:
для комп'ютера, для пульта.
Люди підходили до мене на вулиці,
діставали гаманець, давали гроші.
Так, по крупинці, по крупинці створили радіо.
Є люди, які приходять,
розуміють, що вони спробували,
а далі немає ніякого результату
і вони йдуть, наприклад.
Є ті, хто продовжують робити ефіри,
записи спеціально для нас.
Я кайфую від цього.
Не можу сказати, що у нас є команда,
колектив тому, що це не робота по-перше.
А по-друге, ми ніде не збираємось,
у нас немає літучок, я нікому не роблю
зауважень, хто як хоче так і веде.
У нас повна свобода.
Після того як пробував себе в Києві
і дійшов певного успіху тут.
Успіхом я вважаю просто те,
що про мене дізнались через мою роботу.
Загалом я можу сказати,
що мій ефір слухає близько 100 комп’ютерів.
Серед тих, хто слухає, є люди в Одесі,
у Львові, в Англії, в Німеччині.
Це мене тримає, це мене качає,
що це такий зв'язок.
Як каже одна дівчина:
ми з'єднані електронною ниточкою.
[сміється]
От так радіо — електронна ниточка.
[дзвін дзвонів дзвіниці костелу Святого Юрія]
Я працюю з текстами, а коли ти написав текст,
то можеш до нього повернутись і його виправити.
А коли ти вже сказав,
то ти вже нічого не виправиш.
Слово не горобець, вилетить не спіймаєш.
Так-так, отак приблизно.
Зрозуміло, так, що ти тепер — зірка.
Ну, я б не сказав.
Ні, ну ти взагалі — зірка.
[сміється]
Я постійно читаю твої дописи,
і я коли бачу, що пише Банди, я одразу ага,
відкриваю і дочитую до кінця.
Не знаю ще, чи може нас таких багато,
хто дочитує до кінця.
Різноманітний і мені подобається,
що і з гумором написано і дуже щиро.
Тому що ти розповідаєш такі речі,
які не дуже будеш розказувати,
а коли читаєш  — то інша річ.
Кілька книжок я вже купувала,
мабуть ще одна вийшла, та?
Угу.
Треба ще ту.
Напиши — зустрінемось.
Добре, щасти.
Окей, давай, чао.
Ти дуже хороший і дуже талановитий.
Дякую.
В 1996-1997 я виїхав, працював в Угорщині.
Я викладав українську мову
і історію України в педінституті.
Це був цікавий досвід,
я задоволений, що це зробив.
Але через рік я повернувся назад до Ужгорода.
Я зрозумів, що мені тут краще.
Якби я залишився, я б через 5 років повернувся.
І вважав би ті 5 років трошки втраченим часом.
Все склалося як найкраще.
У цій школі тепер проводжу
радіогурток від 8-го до 11-го класу.
Школа виграла грант, на який закупила техніку,
а я розповідаю, як користуватися цією технікою.
Ми імітуємо ефіри.
Всі діти, які відвідують цей гурток,
будуть ведучими в реальному форматі.
Тут все поруч насправді.
Наприклад, минулого тижня за годину
автівкою ми доїхали до села Липовець.
Звідти піднялися на полонину Руна,
це приблизно 1400 метрів.
Будь-який похід в гори завжди надихає.
І Закарпаття в цьому плані — дуже крутий край.
В Ужгороді така атмосфера
ніби ти всіх знаєш, такий комфорт.
Таке враження, що тобі добра бажають і ти так само.
У великому місті, мені здається, до такого важко дійти.
[вібрує телефон]
Алло...
Прищемив руку?
Передай мамі слухавку.
Що з ним сталось?
Сильно?
Ну я не знаю...
Ви можете перейти сюди?
Ну переходьте,  я відвезу його.
Ми дуже багато часу проводимо на набережній,
яка побудована у міжвоєнний чехословацький період.
Я на цій набережній вже
дуже-дуже багато років з друзями збираюсь.
І думаю, що це унікальне місце.
Адже це великий кайф, коли ти маєш можливість
просто сидіти і дивитися на воду.
Це дуже природно для людини.
Вона почувається у безпеці, почувається спокійно
і їй добре там, де вона є.
Ми цього не усвідомлювали.
Але ми роками на цій набережній,
практично збиралися для того,
аби цією можливістю насолоджуватися.
Ми спілкуємось, говоримо, дуркуємо тощо,
але момент — можливість сидіти і
дивитись на воду — дуже класна річ.
Йди сюди.
[сміється]
Там нічого немає, але треба поістерити.
Де ти прищемив, ти впав?
Цей прищемило,
а тут геть трошки шкіру здерло.
Та, я бачу , що подерся.
Все гаразд?
Хотдог і пепсі?
[сміється]
Ужгород побудований під масштаб людини.
І побудований не нами
і не попереднім поколінням,
це будувалося століттями.
Ну, наприклад, мені тут не потрібна автівка.
Я ходжу собі по молоко в сусідню крамницю.
І за три хвилин вже можу повернутись.
Мені не потрібно кудись їхати,
аби зустрітись з друзями,
мені потрібно просто вийти і пройти сто метрів.
Це економить дуже багато часу,
на роботу і на себе.
Ти виходиш — і ти в гармонійному місці.
Ти відчуваєш тут релакс,
і далі ти можеш займатись своїми речами.